ah in my church group in in Greenfield
Massachusetts
at the age of about 16 or 17 I had made
a deal with my mom and dad I was very
very close to my mom and dad I'm a real
mama's boy and got along with them my
whole life hardly even rough periods and
they went to the Congregationalist
Church the Church of the covered dish
supper in Greenfield Massachusetts
Massachusetts an old enough state that
you could not charter a town without
having a Congregationalist Church and
this was the first one in our town I
mean from back 200 years ago and I made
a deal with my mom and dad that I
wouldn't have to go to church services
Sunday morning if I went to youth group
Sunday night so we had a pastor at that
minister that met at that church that
was fairly hip you know he's trying to
deal with the with the children play a
Jim Morrison song once in a while it
played the Beatle far out and he
sincerely wanted us to to do some
inquiry into theological questions and I
took it very seriously I may have been
the only one in the youth group that did
take it seriously and I read the Bible
cover-to-cover and I think that anyone
who is thinking about maybe being an
atheist if you read the Bible or the
Koran or the Torah cover-to-cover
I believe you will emerge from that as
an atheist I mean you can read The God
Delusion by Richard Dawkins you can read
God is not great by Hitchens but the
Bible itself will turn you atheist
faster than anything
I think because what we get told about
the Bible is is a lot of picking and
fusing when you see you know lots
daughter gang raped and beaten and and
and the Lord being okay with that when
you actually read about Abraham being
willing to kill his son when you
actually read that when you read the
insanity of the talking snake when you
read the hostility towards homosexuals
towards women the celebration of slavery
when you read in context that thou shalt
not kill
means only in your own tribe I mean
there's no hint that it means humanity
in general that there's no sense of a of
a shared humanity it's all tribal when
you see a god that is jealous and
insecure when you see that there's
contradictions that show that it was
clearly written hundreds of years after
the supposed fact and full of
contradictions I think that anybody you
know it's like reading the Constitution
of the United States of America it's
been it's in English you know you don't
need someone to hold your hand just pick
it up and read it just read what the
First Amendment says and then read what
the Bible says going back to the source
material is always the best when
someone's trying to interpret something
for you they always have an agenda so I
read the Bible and then I read you know
Bertrand Russell and I read a lot of
other stuff because in the Greenfield
Public Library the 900s of the Dewey
Decimal System and they were the few
people that still remembers it the 900s
or theology and they're only about this
long but that's all on camera well he
bought this long uh-huh the one-armed
guy who caught a fish this big they're
only about this this long and so I read
a lot of them and I started going into
class and they to his credit the pastor
who was a wonderful man a wonderful man
um would let me talk to him about this
stuff
and finally after I don't know it's so
long ago but after months
of this platonic questioning every night
a youth group the minister called my my
mom and dad and said you know I think
maybe Ben should stop coming to youth
group he's no longer learning about the
Bible from me he is now converting
everyone in the class to atheism so I
was asked to leave very politely very
nicely a youth group and then with the
help of Martin Mull Randy Newman Frank
Zappa the idea that these three men were
out of the closet atheists was so
inspiring to me and so important to me
and reading interviews with somebody and
I remember being somebody in a religious
and I'm not not a religious community
like whack-jobs
but you know in a community where most
everyone was Christian having those
people and interviews say the simple
sentence there is no God meant the world
to me and gave me joy and gave me
passion and gave me love and gave me
confidence and I think the first time I
was interviewed as presumptuous as the
seams and please forgive me I remembered
Frank Zappa's interviews and I wanted to
to give a chance for someone else
reading that to not feel they were alone
now that's less important now I mean the
population of atheists in this country
is going through the roof I mean I'm now
on the side that's winning you know it's
over 20 percent by some polls and I
believe if you counted atheism as a
religion it's the fastest growing
religion in the history of the United
States of America so now I'm on the team
that's winning which is an uncomfortable
position for me but back you know 30
years ago 40 years ago it still felt
like it meant something you know it's
where we're several years behind
gay rights but we're following a much
faster path at acceptance